okay I have a few clips from yesterday's
commander-in-chief forum the the premise
for this event is that NBC and and Matt
Lauer interviewed Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump separately during a sort of
townhall okay I'm gonna play some clips
for you Matt Lauer coward in front of
Donald Trump
he was feeble and flaccid he allowed
Donald Trump to lie lie lie about just
about everything I want to talk about
some of the lies let's go through this
as I like to do piece by piece because
there is so much here one of Donald
Trump's favorite lies is I've always
been against the Iraq war I my decision
against the Iraq war is a winning
decision it's terrific it's tremendous
and I knew all along and I never was
forward I was always against it blah
blah blah blah blah let's listen first
to Donald Trump say that to Matt Lauer
parachute ascends men and women of the
United States into arms well I think the
main thing is I have great judgment I
have good judgment I know what's going
on I've called so many of the shots and
I happened to hear Hillary Clinton say
that I was not against the war in Iraq I
was totally against the war in Iraq from
where you can look at Esquire magazine
from oh four you can look at before that
and I was against the war in Iraq
because I had totally destabilized the
Middle East which it has it has
absolutely been a disastrous war and by
the way perhaps almost as bad was the
way Barack Obama got out no challenge
from the tiny diminutive presence of
Matt Lauer on this thing but
demonstrably false I've played it for
you before and I will play it again as
many times as I need to here is none
other than Donald Trump on the Howard
Stern Show in 2002 saying something that
doesn't exactly sound like opposition to
the Iraq war
take a listen I know they're skulking
around somewhere and you just feel like
you're sitting duck but we have an idea
that the enemy isn't a lot of times the
politicians don't want to tell you that
are you for invading Iraq yeah I guess
you know I wish it was I wish the first
time it was done correctly mm-hmm
interesting not exactly I'm against the
Iraq war is it but Matt Lauer coward and
just moved on to the next question
so then Donald Trump said yesterday that
he was absolutely right when back in
2013 he blamed sexual assault in the
military on men and women serving
together in the Armed Forces Matt Lauer
asked him about that claim and Trump
restated I stand by that let's go to
that piece of video the court system
practically doesn't exist in 2001 in
2013 on this subject you tweeted this
quote 26,000 unreported sexual assaults
in the military only 238 convictions
what did these geniuses expect when they
put men and women together well it is it
is a it is a correct tweet there are
many people that think that that's
absolutely correct and we need a happy
place we expect it and does that mean
the only way to place it is to take
women's happen out of the military and
by the way since then it's gotten worse
no not to kick him out but something has
to be happened you right now part of the
problem is nobody gets prosecuted you
have reported and the gentleman can tell
you so it some of what Donald Trump is
getting to about the lack of prosecution
for sexual assault in the military it's
an issue and it is being dealt with and
I'll talk about that this is the epitome
of the Trump weasel language it's a
correct tweet because there are many
people that think the tweet is correct
not exactly presenting a waterfall of
evidence there is he finally it seems
like Matt Lauer woke up during this
thing I don't know what exactly they
expected right I mean did you expect men
and women of the military to serve
together and not sexually assault each
other I really take issue with Trump's
characterization that just men and women
together is responsible for sexual
assault it's an insult to the troops
really to say that in spite of the
supposed professionalism of the military
there's just no way that these
professionals who people like Trump
often like the claim or the best in the
world would be able to resist sexually
assaulting each other I think that that
is a huge huge insult to the military
and we've talked about the mechanisms in
the military that are causing these
problems we've talked about the sharp
program which is pushing a totally
zero-tolerance policy on sexual assault
we know that intervention training is up
we know that prosecutions are up etc
this is an opportunity for Trump to
number one critique Obama for something
that actually President Obama has made
progress on and number two also to just
put out there yet another myth which is
that you just can't have men and women
together even if they're the best
professionals in the any military on
this planet they can't be together and
lastly of course no Donald Trump town
hall is complete until he praises
Russian President Vladimir Putin let's
take a look at that video here if he
says great things about me I'm gonna say
great things about him I've already said
he is really very much of a leader I
mean you can say oh isn't that a
terrible thing he called him and the man
has very strong control over a country
now it's a very different system and I
don't happen to like the system but
certainly in that system he's been a
leader far more than our president has
been a leader we have a divided country
yeah we have a country where you have
Hillary Clinton with her emails that
nobody has ever seen where she deleted
right but Russian President Vladimir
Putin is a way better leader than
President Obama I like when they cut too
and if you were listening you wouldn't
have seen this they cut too so this I
mean there were a lot of members of the
military in this thing it was sort of
the premise of this Town Hall they cut
too for military guys who I may be
reading their facial expressions
incorrectly but they seem very disturbed
by the fact that Donald Trump is trying
to get himself elected and talking about
what a great leader Vladimir Putin is
even though he doesn't particularly
agree with the system of which Putin is
that leader that's it so terrible
terrible performance by Matt Lauer the
Hillary Clinton interview was really not
much better but Donald Trump just lying
and lying and lying - absolutely no and
and the scary part and really what what
keeps me thinking that maybe my view is
wrong about these events is that there
are problem
low information voters who see this
nonsense and think you know what Trump
sounded pretty good
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing